bye
back in the Middle Ages they're probably
infectious diseases that we'd hit a
village would wipe everybody out and
then there were no humans near enough
for the virus to jump to so over just
died out now in this day and age where
the earth is much more populated than it
was in the Middle Ages where we have jet
travel where we've moved into areas like
the rainforest where there's a lot of
species of microbes and things that
we've come in contact with that we
didn't in the Middle Ages there's much
more likelihood that new diseases will
spring up we saw this even before jet
travel really took off and that was in
1918 where we had the influenza epidemic
there were 50 to 100 million people is
the estimate that died that's a third
the population of Europe at the time and
500 million people were infected that's
a third the population in the world
population was 1.6 billion back in 1918